if you change the picture in your mind
you change the chemistry change the fate
so i'll give an example
if i have a picture of love in my mind
the brain releases complementary
chemistry dopamine pleasure
oxytocin bond with your loved one growth
hormone which does exactly what it says
it enhances your growth and that's why
when people fall in love the chemistry
of the brain going into the blood the
culture medium enhances vitality people
glow when they fall in love people are
healthy when they fall in love this is
not an accident it's the chemistry of
your culture medium
but now i say but wait what if i have a
picture of fear
i go oh well love chemistry doesn't come
out when fear is in the picture the
brain releases stress hormones and
factors that affect the immune system
and growth of the system and i go oh my
goodness i say why is it relevant
changing my thought changes my chemistry
the chemistry adjust my biology